so a 24 year old living in dubai who's
originally from london got arrested
because
he was approached by police officers
that said they heard he had drugs in his
system and in dubai that's illegal so he
did a drug test it all came back
negative so they then asked can we
search your car and your apartment he
said go ahead i don't do drugs so i have
nothing to worry about they actually
found four small bottles of cbd oil in
his car along with some loose cash
so they arrested him and after spending
a few five years after spending a few
days in prison and uh he's trying to get
a legal team together to help him he was
actually given a piece of paper told to
sign he didn't know what he was signing
it was actually a paper admitting that
he not only is doing drugs but he's
selling jesus which then uh brought his
sentence from what could have been a few
years in a prison in dubai 25. just even
so when i lived in saudi arabia i was
four i was 13 years old 14 years old and
a 14 year old in dahran
that year was caught with a joint and
they put her in jail for 25 years and
there was nothing so in the middle east
they don't [ __ ] around
and then my friend was selling furniture
in the middle east he was making
furniture and selling it
and he uh
some of his friends were smoking weed
and they were bringing weed in from you
get really good hashish there right and
they brought some hash in from turkey
and they were they had a party well they
got caught and my friend
laughed and i said why did he goes
because my friends got their head couple
of them got their heads cut off
because distributing for being for being
drug distributors
they don't [ __ ] around with that stuff
they don't [ __ ] around that's such a
shame for that guy with cbd yeah so his
parents right now are working on having
the embassy actually help a mountain see
if
they can try to get him out somehow
because there wasn't any in his system
so they were trying to get him on the
fact that he was selling ah dang that's
so tough he's gone away for a little bit
though yeah